- [Man] All right, Cassie,
- Hi.
- [Man] Cassie, where are
you from? Where'd you go?
- I am from Pomona, California.
- [Man] And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were a kid.
- [Man] Yes. My family
used to be in my life
but I don't talk to them
really because yeah,
long story but I don't
want to not really talk
about it right now,
alcoholics pretty much.
- [Man] And tell me about your childhood.
How was it?
- My childhood was good.
I was raised right, but
I continue to do wrong.
That's my choices. You know what I mean?
But I'm trying to change
that as a new year.
And my new year's resolution is to
finish something that I started.
Finish my accomplishments
and, you know, reach my goals.
- [Man] What do you wanna do this year?
- What I want to do this year?
I want to get my own place
and I want to get my kids back
and I just want to do
good in life, you know.
- [Man] How many kids you got?
- I got two.
- [Man] How old?
- My son's five years old
and my daughter is one.
- [Man] And is the dad in the picture.
- No, he's not.
- [Man] So you're working,
are you working Figaro street?
- I don't work no streets.
- [Man] You do it over the internet?
- I don't do internet either.
- [Man] What do you do?
- I just do what my, whatever
my mind tells me to do.
- [Man] Do you work as a prostitute?
- No.
- [Man] You don't?
- [Man] Then what are we doing here?
- Well, what am I doing here?
Well, I used to, but you know,
I have regulars, you know?
(Cassie laughs)
And I like to be a nasty girl sometimes.
(Cassie mews)
- [Man] And do guys pay you
for money sometimes to do that.
- Sometimes yeah. There's some, yeah.
- [Man] How much do they pay you?
- Depending on what they want.
- [Man] What's the nastiest
thing they've asked for?
- CIP.
- What's CIP?
- Come in Pussy.
- [Man] Oh, is that right?
- Yeah.
BB BBJ, Bare back blowjob
all that, you know?
- [Man] And you do this sometimes?
- Sometimes.
It's been a long time
since I've done it though.
You know, I don't really put
myself out there like that
unless that I it's a regular,
you know what I mean?
- [Man] How much does,
how much does a C whatever a BB whatever?
- Like $600.
- [Man] $600?
- Yeah. Sometimes more than that.
Sometimes $ 1000, whatever.
- [Man] It's a risky way to...
- Oh, it's too much. Sometimes I do like,
yeah 600.
- [Man] That's a risky way
to make, make a living.
- I mean, yeah, it really is.
I've been through a
lot of stuff, you know.
- [Man] What's the craziest
stuff you've been through.
- Okay, well, I was in
Pomona and this guy,
it was very late
and this guy said he's gonna
give me some money right?
So he's reaching in his pocket.
I get in the car with him
and he's trying to find like a dark spot.
And then we go in the car and
he finds a dark spot finally.
And then he like, I said,
okay give me my money.
Like not trying to be rude or nothing.
I'm not a rude person, but he's like,
I said okay, can I have
my money first, you know?
And he's all like, yeah sure.
And then he reaches in his pocket
by the driver door and then
he pulls a knife out
and I'm like, sitting like this.
I don't want to put my legs
up like that right now.
Or should I?
- [Man] No.
- No, okay. Well, I was sitting like this
in the passenger seat.
And then like, he put a
knife to my neck, right?
So I'm like pushing him
towards the windshield
and like kicking him and all that.
And then like, it was just crazy.
And then he didn't, he couldn't get
to my neck and slice my throat.
Like, I don't know what the whole
the whole point in that was,
but I was just like
I didn't have no money or nothing.
So it's not like he was
going to rob me, you know?
Like I didn't have nothing to take
and it's just like stupid to me.
But I was really scared.
And after that,
I still do what I did.
But like I slowed down a
lot because of my daughter.
Honestly, I'm trying to
get my life together now.
You know?
- [Man] How, how old were
you when you started?
- I was 18.
19.
- [Man] How old are you now?
- I'm 24.
- [Man] 24.
You've not worked for the pimp?
- Never.
- [Man] Never.
- I mean well, yeah,
honestly I have, yeah.
I have before, yeah.
But,
I am a rather Renegade now.
Whatever you wanna call it, I don't care.
- [Man] (indistinct) that?
- Just independence.
- [Man] Did guys still pressure you
to come up with some money on the street?
- I mean, they always come to me
cause I'm not an ugly girl.
You know what I mean?
Like they come to me regularly.
Like I don't even try to put
myself out there like that.
They just come up to me,
you know what I mean?
Like, I can't help it.
Sometimes I'd be like,
no, get away from me.
Even if they're offering me money.
But sometimes like, all
money is not good money.
I've learned that by this
dollar sign on my face.
And I've been through a
lot of stuff in my life.
- [Man] No, but I guess my question was,
does working as a Renegade
still cost you money or some of the...
- I mean yeah I have my living expenses.
- [Man] But like from
the thugs on the street?
- No, not really. Because
I don't have to pay nobody.
- [Man] You don't, because
some of the girls do.
- Yeah. I don't.
- [Man] Yeah. Good for you.
- I don't put myself.
I don't really talk to too many people.
I keep my circle small, always.
There's lot of snakes
out there in the grass,
you know I gotta keep my grass cut low,
but anyways...
- And Karma, tell me about karma.
- Ooh, Karma is a bitch.
Sorry. Excuse my language.
Karma is a mother effer, you know?
- [Man] Is it hard doing this kind of work
and then dealing with that?
- Not really, cause I don't
do grammy shit to people.
I don't do grammy stuff.
I don't do dirty stuff to people anymore.
I have.
But when you do dirty stuffs to people
it's like that karma comes back to you.
You don't know which way
it's going to hit you.
It could hit you up down,
left, right. You know.
Like for real, like you don't know
it could be good or bad.
And my advice is not to do
nobody dirty or else that shit
Will come back to you
and we don't want that.
- [Man] So you mentioned
before you started speaking
on camera about wanting to get out.
- Wanting to what?
- [Man] Wanting to get out of this life
- Yeah, I do. I do.
I want to raise my kids.
I don't want my daughter to
grow up like me you know.
Cause my life is hard.
It was hard, but not too hard.
Other people have it worse.
I need to really look at my
situation and other people's.
My situation is not that
bad as other people.
Cause I still have time
to get my stuff together.
You know?
- [Man] Did you finish high school?
- No. I'm working on that now.
- [Man] And what would you
like to do, you're 24 so you...
- I want to do nursing.
- [Man] That would probably
be a better lifestyle
than doing this.
- Yeah, honestly, well. I know.
- [Man] Especially for the kids.
- Yeah. They're young,
they're babies too, you know.
- [Man] Everyday you go
out every night you go out.
- Not really.
I don't go out every night.
- [Man] No but I'm just
saying every time you work,
you're risking your kids.
- Yeah. Taking big chances.
- [Man] And that's gotta be a big concern.
- Yeah.
- [Man] You get depressed sometimes?
- No. I don't cry a lot.
Only when shit builds up a lot, you know?
And then I cry.
Other times I'll just spaz out on somebody
like my boyfriend, well, my ex whatever.
He broke my phone and stuff, you know?
So like he's an asshole?
He don't want me to do nothing
stupid and illegal for money.
And he'd rather get a job,
but I feel like I'm independent
and I don't want to depend on him anymore.
So I said fuck him and I left
because he broke my phone.
So fuck him, I haven't
talked to him since.
- [Man] Your relationships with men.
Have they been...
- Hmm
- [Man] Have you had problems in
your relationships with men?
- [Cassie] Yeah, I think he's gay.
- [Man] That'd be a problem?
- [Cassie] Yeah. Like, I don't know.
He has a friend.
This boy or whatever, he's a white boy.
But my ex he's black, whatever.
And he works like out at CBD
warehouse, whatever thingy.
But anyways,
like he tried to help me
and have me work and labor works like
packages and shit.
And his friend worked there too
and they were like this.
But he's like always trying to blow me off
for his friend and shit.
And I feel like he's gay low key.
And like, I don't know I'm so over it.
- [Man] Where would you like
to see your life in five,
ten years?
- Having my own mansion or something
or a condo
or a two story house
with my kids.
Maybe have more kids
and have my dream car,
which is I don't know what car yet but.
- [Man] So where, where
are your kids right now?
- My kids right now
are in the system
of San Bernardino
and I'm working on trying
to get my kids back.
And I'm doing what I gotta do
and I'm gonna keep doing it.
- [Man] And drugs. Tell me about that.
- I mess around here and there.
That's my problem of getting my kids back.
Because I tested positive
when I had my daughter
of Crystal meth, whatever
methamphetamines.
But honestly I know how to handle it.
I know how to handle it
and I know how to stop.
It's not like it's
Oh my God, Like, Oh my God, I need it.
You know what I mean?
Like it's not all like that at all.
You know? Like straight up, it's not.
- [Man] What does that
crystal meth do for you.
- It takes my problems
away for the moment.
But when that moment's gone,
my problems come back.
It's not worth it really
It's hard to stop (indistinct),
but you know what?
You just gotta be strong and have faith,
either it's kids or the meth.
And the mat is not
worth more than my kids.
My kid means every, my
kids mean everything to me.
And I just want to get my life together
and just stop everything.
Honestly, you know.
Just gotta surround yourself
around positive people.
That's it.
- [Man] And your relationship
with your family, how's that?
- It's good.
I talked to them here and there.
Just keep it short, you know.
- [Man] What's the most
difficult part of your life.
The fact that your kids are...
- My kids being gone.
- [Man] Your kids are gone?
- Yeah. Pretty much.
- [Man] That's gotta
make you crazy, right?
- Yeah.
- [Man] As a mom.
- [Man] What was the
best time of your life?
- My 18'th birthday, I went
to Vegas and got so faded.
- [Man] And what's been the worst time?
- Thinking about my kids.
- [Man] Yeah.
What is it about this lifestyle
that keeps you stuck?
Cause you seem to, like...
- [Man] I'm not stuck, it's just
Not being able to be with my parents
and live with my parents because
I always got to walk on eggshells.
You know what I mean?
I think that's the only
thing keeping back.
Me having to walk on eggshells
to still having that
respect for my parents.
You know what I mean?
I don't have to live with
my parents all the time.
Just I run into fucked up people.
- [Man] You been in love before?
- Have I what?
- [Man] Been in love?
- Yeah, my, the one I loved, he died.
Yeah. He lived in Compton.
He got stabbed.
He used got gambling shacks and shit.
And it just, he started
taking all my money
and gambling and all that.
And when I got fed up with it,
cause he wasn't doing shit
and I was taking care of us.
And like he would just
gamble all my money,
our money whatever my money
really.
If you want to get technical.
And yeah, pretty much
just got tired of it.
You know, I was tired of everything.
Yeah.
- [Man] So when these guys
asked you to do these extreme
or dangerous things with them,
do you have regrets later about...
- No I don't never regret nothing
or I never do it.
- [Man] Or you never do it?
- I wouldn't do it if I
ever had to regret it.
- [Man] So you do it,
but you just move on?
- Yeah.
- [Man] What about STDs
and stuff like that?
- No. I've never gotten.
- [Man] Never had anything.
- No.
- [Man] You're lucky.
What's the most important
lesson you've learned?
Or have you?
- Stay protected.
(both laugh)
- [Man] You're a contradiction darling?
- [Cassie] Yeah, so my
daughter came along.
I didn't plan that, didn't want it,
but you know, four baby downs to be here.
- [Man] All right Cassie.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with me.
- Thank you so much it
was nice seeing you guys.
- [Man] I wish you the best of luck
in turning your life around.
- Thank you. ( kissing sound)
Sorry. So nervous.
Ew, my ears' so ugly.